jeffrey for you do you remember the
first time you
saw the emotions from the killer whale
well
whether it was tilikum or one of the
other whales do you remember the first
time you kind of looked into
this creature's eyes and saw that
something was there sure they're very
expressive
on day one i mean you can't mistake that
you can tell when they're happy you can
tell when they're upset you can tell
when they're being aggressive
um really easy to detect in all
cetaceans and most of the
animals at seaworld yeah and why did you
leave seaworld
um i was outspoken and i actually lost
my job at seaworld
for being outspoken yeah uh do you feel
that there is no place for
animals and entertainment um
entertainment probably not um i have no
problem with
zoos and uh a place to retire elephants
to for example
i'm not anti-sea world i just think the
the days of the dancing bear have ended
and
it's time to move on we're at this
evolutionary point i think globally and
that's
i think one of the reasons the film is
so effective
you